lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
analizar con más detalle el concepto de
intervalos de confianza en otros vídeos
los hemos calculado e incluso los hemos
interpretado pero aquí nos aseguraremos
de hacer las suposiciones correctas para
tener certeza de nuestros intervalos de
confianza para hacer ciudadanos de que
los calculamos correctamente y en el
contexto correcto como repaso recordemos
que lo que hacemos en los intervalos de
confianza es tratar de estimar un
parámetro de la población quizá queremos
conocer la proporción de la población
que votó por cierto candidato no podemos
encuestar a toda la población por lo que
tomamos una muestra y de esta calculamos
la proporción muestral después usamos
esta proporción muestral para calcular
un intervalo de confianza a ambos lados
de dicha proporción muestral y sabemos
que si hacemos esto muchas veces cada
vez que lo hacemos no sólo es probable
que tengamos una proporción muestral
diferente la cual es el centro del
intervalo sino que también tendremos
diferentes márgenes de error pues usamos
la proporción muestral para calcular los
la primera suposición que tiene que
cumplirse para que podamos confiar en el
intervalo de confianza es que la
muestra sea aleatoria si tratamos de
estimar la proporción de personas que
quieren votar por cierto candidato pero
solo encuestamos a personas de la
tercera edad no tendremos una muestra
aleatoria como todo en la estadística
siempre debemos asegurarnos de tener
muestras aleatorias otra suposición que
se debe cumplir es una conocida como la
condición de normalidad recuerden que la
construcción de los intervalos de
confianza se fundamenta en que la
distribución muestral de la proporción
muestral debe tener aproximadamente una
forma normal pero para poder hacer esta
suposición debemos tener esta condición
de normalidad y la regla general es que
por cada muestra debemos esperar más de
10 éxitos y más de 10 fracasos para cada
muestra por ejemplo si el tamaño de la
muestra fuera igual a 10 e imaginamos
que la proporción verdadera es 50% o 0.5
entonces no se cumple la condición de
normalidad pues esperaríamos 5 éxitos y
5 fracasos en cada muestra pero
usualmente no conocemos el parámetro de
la población cuando calculamos
intervalos de confianza así que lo que
hacemos es verla
y calcular los éxitos y los fracasos que
tenemos si tenemos menos de 10 en alguno
de estos entonces tendremos un problema
ya que debemos obtener 10 o más tanto
éxitos como fracasos incluso no es que
debamos esperar porque vamos a tomar una
muestra y simplemente vamos a contar
cuántos éxitos y fracasos tenemos si
esto no se cumple entonces no se cumple
la condición de normalidad por lo que no
tendremos un intervalo de confianza
válido la tercera condición es la de
independencia o la regla del 10% si
muestra mos si en reemplazo y en
ocasiones es difícil muestrear con
reemplazo por ejemplo si encuestamos a
personas cuando salen de un centro
comercial no podemos pedirles que
vuelvan a entrar para que tengamos una
muestra con reemplazo la condición de
independencia dice que si el tamaño de
la muestra el cual denominamos n es
menor al 10% de la población por ejemplo
imaginemos que la población es de
100.000 personas y encuestamos a 1000
personas oa un 1% de la población
entonces podemos confiar en que la
condición de independencia se cumple
recuerden que esto se aplica cuando
muestre amos sin reemplazo para apreciar
el porqué los intervalos de confianza no
son confiables cuando no se cumple
alguna de estas condiciones y me voy a
enfocar en las últimas dos porque el que
la muestra sea aleatoria es
tremendamente importante en toda la
estadística primero veamos lo que sucede
cuando no se cumple la condición de
independencia aquí tenemos una pantalla
de un simulador de dulces y en esta
simulación establecimos que la
proporción de la población es del 60%
aunque quien tome las muestras no sabe
esto tratamos de construir intervalos
con un nivel de confianza del 95% e
indicamos que no hay reemplazo por lo
que cada elemento que muestre amos no lo
regresamos a la población también
determinamos que el tamaño de la muestra
es mucho más grande que el 10% de la
población aquí tomamos muchas muestras
casi en 1500 de tamaño 200 podemos ver
en negro los casos en donde el parámetro
verdadero de la población está contenido
en el intervalo de confianza que
calculamos para dicha muestra y en rojo
a aquellos que no incluyen el parámetro
verdadero de la población vemos que los
aciertos no llegan al 93% y que tenemos
un número
y grande demuestras si este nivel de
confianza fuera realmente del 95 por
ciento aquí deberíamos ver algo muy
cercano al 95 por ciento ahora veamos lo
que sucede cuando no se cumple la
condición de normalidad en el simulador
determinamos que el tamaño de la muestra
es 15 incluso la misma simulación nos
advierte que se espera en menos de 10
fallos con esta configuración también
tomamos muchas muestras más de 2000 y
aún cuando quiero tener intervalos de
confianza que a medida que vaya
calculando cada vez más y más tengamos
un porcentaje de éxitos cercano al 95%
resulta que sólo tengo un 94 por ciento
de éxitos aún cuando tome muchas
muestras lo importante aquí es que si la
muestra no es aleatoria no nos va a
servir pero si no confiamos en que la
distribución muestral de las muestras
sea normal o si el tamaño de las
muestras es más grande que el 10% de la
población y no reemplazamos es decir
violamos la condición de independencia
entonces el nivel de confianza que
tratamos de calcular podría ser no
válido
nos vemos en otro vídeo